[Music]
so you guys have experienced losing a
dog like Miss a lot Oh tell me about it
[ __ ] miss what that happened to
okay yeah all right you pray to God and
I need a key to keep your promise and I
sob question so as what happen I lived
in a condo kind of like similar to yours
word that garages on the bottom and then
as I was pulling out that day that doggy
ran out my doggy Brown he was following
me
and he disappeared and I was like where
the [ __ ] is he but roommates didn't know
so after I came back we printed out
these reward things we [ __ ] you know
like you know the picture of his cute
ass face and I was like dollars
[ __ ] give me a reward I'll give
you a reward for this dog went number
everything I went through the whole damn
town and I've plastered it and I was in
my [ __ ] living room like I'm never
[ __ ] lost a dog before goddamnit we
kind know I almost did though but I
started painted Jesus at this was like
you know it's been a long time homie
yeah just give me this one thing I
promise I'll go back to church and as
soon as I said that I heard my neighbor
was a it was a girl she was like I
wonder who the owner is
and she's walking through the front and
I and I hear the fire Brown running back
in I'm like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
miracle happened right I gave her three
hundred bucks and I was like thank you
[ __ ] got Brown never went back to
church that's probably why he died
that's why he probably died oh jesus
[ __ ] took him away from you Jesus is
like I'll give him one more day and I'm
killing that [ __ ] dog yeah like you
must really love that dog I'm bringing
him up here no I'm saying if you wanted
to keep the dog
yep no you know he just knows your heart
dude he's like I wanna give this dog
back shells not going back to church but
he can happily just probably walk into
Church in heaven and he's like he's a
[ __ ] my dog got out music oh
take that cute dog Brown that's good and
now he's up there like you guys you guys
watch JK news this is [ __ ] Joe's dog
Joe's not yeah really really to answer
your question yes we know what it's like
you lost braking braking and then Tyson
what the hell I've lost Tyson multiple
times bond [ __ ] is [ __ ] fun so many
times okay there's something wrong with
our dogs or us and it's normal I've been
with the old dogs they just get they're
trying to get away I don't know I think
that's normal from something in the home
there's gotta be something you know
maybe tall people are dogs every time
you never have a bad it's okay
that literally by now so this story here
this dog was missing for three years oh
my god yeah oh yeah so this dog so this
this terrier makes named hazel so the
owner named Monica she just one day like
she the dog just ran away so they were
trying to find this dog hazel but three
years passed so she went she moved from
Iowa to Minnesota and then recently she
discovered she ended up coming across
this Florida breweries promotion where
they are putting shelter dogs faces on
beer cans and that's when she discovered
her dog was on one of these cans
it's like those missing children on the
milk wow she's like that's my [ __ ] dog
miss hazal damn she's like that's my
daughter Florida they have no idea how
she got where I was to Florida like
that's crazy
maybe you jumped on a road trip ride
with
meth deliver and then somehow I want to
know what the story was
it's like babe they interview the dog
the dog said he said it was wrong that's
not what dogs sound like that's
offensive
you don't own dogs so you don't know
I've had dogs we cope ruff ruff yeah
they she knows what's up you you guys
are stereotyping back a little eyebrows
a little we need to fill in those
eyebrows but family photos like oh
because like she contacted this brewery
which then connected her to the shelter
and then so she was trying to tell this
shelter like that's my dog don't please
don't let her get adopted I'm gonna lose
her again so then they were like well we
need some sort of proof so then she
pulled up like you know family photos
and like that is the most camouflage and
shirt I've ever seen you just you're
floating oh my god
that's very good lanes I didn't notice a
kid back there oh yeah it works unless
thought guys what is the kid Wayne grass
how you know that's the dog dog that's a
puppy if there's one sock on we acid in
the Monica that's the dog damn it did
change a movie with a dog like this the
dog on the right looks like homebound
chance you see the dog on the right we
think he looks like he drinks those
beers that guy you can't even see his
eyes and she you see tongue the black
one yeah so luckily she found her dog
and then sewed what's a wild the shelter
also said that they were there they
covered the expenses of returning the
dog to Minnesota now because she lived
in Iowa and she lost the dog and then
somehow the doggy gets away and they
find them in a California shelter yeah
all right he's is there a road trip and
as dogs
how's happening with BSO then easy
it's kind of awesome how this this
promotion helps reunite their dog in the
owner someone probably picked up the
doggie
and then like it lived at this place and
then the dogs ran away and I lived at
another place doggie ran away like he
just continuously just couchsurfing he
was looking healthy he doesn't look
hungry you know because our dog was like
several cities over and we're like how
the [ __ ] did you get here but it ended
up that so she was like on the side of
the freeway stupid-ass dog and then a
lady saw her and was like oh I love you
and took her in and then she was gonna
adopt her and then that's when I found a
chip and then they're like nope you
can't take her so then they left her
there
oh they may be like a couple fans huh
they just they find it you have to
confiscate the dogs that they're like
wait this dog is in yours
dogs already has another owner so then
when you said they leave it though they
and then they called you guys there how
does that we she was trying to adopted
so that all the paperwork could be under
the baby's name okay and then when they
did this the chipping and like just to
check all her stuff they found that
she's chip yeah so that means she
already has previous owners so because
there's a chip they're like oh we can't
release this dog to you anymore anymore
so I remember the [ __ ] up part was
that they were just gonna like have a
certain amount of time that they were
gonna leave breather and then they were
gonna put her down oh it wasn't for fans
like [ __ ] really yeah yeah wait so they
didn't call you this well this is the
weird thing so when we fat we how'd it
happen I think when we adopted her they
checked for chips and there was none
mm-hmm but then that second time when
she got away they did it and there was a
chip and they called those owners yeah
so y'all didn't find the chip that was
already there no when we got her scanned
at all I know I think we have a faulty
vet that we've been going to didn't call
you guys they called the og owner yeah
because that's the information that's
connected to the chill heart at the fans
oh they kept looking at all the shelter
like the website and they're like I
think that's her
the fans are [ __ ] awesome we can
assemble them fans go find my left nut I
lost it there's chicken the UK is like
hey I think you look though this brothel
[Laughter]
they call the original owners and then
have the dog then they call and they
were like hey this person's claiming
that they cuz I'm like no she's kind of
famous she's in all these videos like
she has a following too and they were
like ok well we see that she's yours but
we still have to clear it by the
original people were then they were like
yeah we don't give a [ __ ] about her like
we can have her oh thank you that's
amazing
I don't know worked like that yeah so
cheap your pets we could have been a JK
news article yeah I lost a lot of cats
to Coyotes man [ __ ] coyote how do you
know them yeah but like how do you know
like oh they see the remains
yeah we found the caller's phone almost
died and got with by two years ago four
of them surrounded her how did she
escape so we saw her house is getting
worked on right now um so they have to
tear down one of the walls and I'm sure
you guys are videos
yes specifically her she can jump she
can clear six-foot wall like nothing so
they put a board like they're really
courteous so they put a board but it's
not six feet tall so when she she has
the doggy door she comes in and out up
so she disappear whatever she's just
self-regulated um so she did that and I
guess she wanted to explore so she's out
like 1:00 in the morning and she's like
exploring this is all the surveillance
footage that I saw so she's exploring
and stuff and then she sees a coyote and
she loves dogs so she didn't know it was
a coyote is she like you could see her
she's happy she's like a friend and she
runs up to it and then immediately the
other three surround her yeah yeah it's
pretty tight so she's in the middle and
she's like oh [ __ ] so she's backing up
and then one like bites her and she's
like and then like the other three back
off but like the leader one keeps trying
to like nip at her to see like if she's
gonna do anything and she like kept
moving enough to where like she like
stood her ground and the other ones cut
Wow you have a video that yeah that's
pretty crazy yeah well good thing she
got away
thank God I know how did she get back in
I don't know she's just hopped the fence
we stopped some
playing sports on too many blind spots
we can't play the video on jakey news or
the video gets taken down why video well
it seems like every time we play video
game play videos sorry guys I can't play
my own video hole videos I would the
owner of the Coyotes put a copyright
strike against me imagine everyone's
doing that now though like they get the
license for whatever video real quick
and then they just [ __ ] start
dragging people down lawsuits yeah I got
I got some of my videos Rd monetized
it's my football - it's like it's weird
because if you have your your music
monetize through iTunes and stuff like
that yeah so my own music is like it's
listed as if people use it in YouTube
videos
oh your videos on your own channel I
mean it's like it's some it's another
thing I just didn't do so it's like I I
lifted my [ __ ] on iTunes like it'll get
you know if people use my music they'll
get D monetized where I get that revenue
so IB I was getting these emails it's
like this music video he has you know
copyright claim I'm like by who it's
like tune core oh [ __ ]
because I'm I did that so it's like but
I'm like who cares I'm getting the
revenue either way so I'm like yeah
whatever yeah it's just confusing at
first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]